(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Located in
the town of Patan, in India
is a 90-foot-deep stepwell,
with an even deeper
connection to the past.
(upbeat music)
Built inside an opening in the ground,
approximately 200 feet
long and 65 feet wide,
the stepwell is designed as a
seven level, inverted temple.
Throughout history, most
monuments have been constructed
by men with the intention
of honoring their wives.
However, Rani ki vav is different
as it was initially built
as a memorial to the king
in the 11th century AD, by his wife.
Hence, it became known
as the Queen's Stepwell.
In the past stepwells were
common throughout India.
These wells were primarily
used to collect water.
However, they also became
a place of socializing
and an important aspect of the community
to people of the time.
It features more than
500 principle sculptures
and at least 1,000 smaller sculptures,
all in religious or mythological imagery.
At the trend's peak, there were
roughly 3,000 stepwells in India.
However, today, only around 1,000 remain.
Rani ki vav serves as a
valuable visual history
to teach and remind visitors
about the traditions of the past.
(light music)
(ringing music)